Thanksgiving is about food family and
the systematic extermination of Native
Americans through land theft and disease
but for most of us it's also that time
of year when we will be visiting with
that relative yes that one that
misinformed uncle one too many glasses
of wine aunt casually racist grandpa or
angsty texting teenage cousin
conversation with these lunatics can be
challenging that's why we here at aj+
have devised these simple strategies to
help you navigate those can't win dinner
debates and turn your waking Turkey
nightmare into a tryptophan induced
dream before you can even begin stuffing
your faces with stuffing you're
misinformed
uncle sends a polar vortex of stupidity
flying across the room cold as hell out
there you ask me there's nothing warming
about this globe
freeze now you an informed sane person
might want to drop little climate
knowledge about carbon parts per million
and the acidification of the oceans but
remember climate change deniers have
heard the facts before and disregarded
all of them so save your breath it's one
less carbon emission instead we kindly
mentioned that October was actually the
warmest month in recorded history and
deflect with a joke like won't everyone
miss Florida when it's gone okay bad
example
dinner is served the yams are candying
the potatoes are mashing and the gravy
is congealing somewhere around your
aorta
that's when grandpa dusts off the casual
racists greatest hits and pipes up about
immigrants those immigrants are stealing
our jobs and ruining America thanks to
Obamacare
hold that thought in fact hold all
thoughts grandpa thinks thoughts are
clear where do you even start grandpa
who is of German and Irish descent wants
to build a wall to cut off America's
oldest yet freshest resource even
through enough thanks Obamacare to tempt
you don't take the bait gently explain
Obamacare has nothing to do with
immigration policy start carving the
turkey and do not fret casual racist
Gramps will be in a food coma by 6:00
it's finally turkey time but your wino
aunt has had one too many already and
believes right now is the perfect moment
to freak out about Ebola I heard this
doctor got Ebola hopped on his bicycle
and went bowling all night long we're
all gonna die no matter how hard you
wash scrub or quarantine your dinner
table won't be immune to idiocy but
instead of engaging your aunt about
ocular bleeding next to the cranberry
sauce remind her that unless she's a
reckless poop enthusiast fishing through
Hospital septic tanks in West Africa
she's probably not getting Ebola then
ask her she got a new haircut even
though she's been rockin the same do
since 85 she'll think her haircut still
looks fresh and switched to water
and no turkey dinner conversation is
safe from your angsty texting teenage
cousin she isn't keeping up with the
news but she is keeping up with the
kardashians and won't hesitate to chime
in on glue do gate oh my god did you see
Kim K's buy pick do not engage we repeat
do not engage Kim Kardashian and her
backside survive and thrive on your
commentary so don't be part of the
problem be part of the solution your
teenage texting cousin can't even but
you really seriously can't even divert
distract immediately change the subject
can someone pass the stuffing oh man
stuffing is the best why don't we eat
stuffing all the time
your teenage cousin will instantly lose
focus and go back to texting so you're
just gonna sit there and watch me clean
typical what you thought you were
perfect incapable of screwing up
Thanksgiving dinner in your own right
get over yourself
you have issues too but now is not the
time to air them sure your dad missed
your piano recital and now you're
incapable of meaningful human
relationships but that can wait for your
therapist Thanksgiving is not a therapy
session this is important folks
Thanksgiving is not a therapy session if
you follow these simple guidelines you
will help your dysfunctional family
dinner function like a well-oiled
machine maybe don't mention oil try
Black Friday sales no too many tempies
football too much domestic violence I
know
Matthew McConaughey whatever it is stay
sane and Happy Thanksgiving